the gay story of the week we seem to
have one every week special or there
should be some glitter flying around me
when we do that can we get some strobe
lights maybe so you know there's been
this whole big thing about the anti-gay
laws in Uganda everybody's been talking
about that of course we just had the
Olympics in Sochi and Russia has these
laws about gay propaganda I came across
this map but that's on the United
Nations website about countries and gay
laws okay so the seventy seventy eight
countries right now estimated by the UN
ban homosexuality just a couple of them
and these are the dark red ones
Afghanistan Egypt Jamaica India Pakistan
that means it is completely illegal
seven countries right now allowed the
death penalty for having consensual
homosexual relationships that includes
our good buddies over in Iran right now
Nigeria Saudi Arabia Sudan and Yemen now
of course we can see the red the red is
the red is the bad part I think there is
two interesting pieces in the midst of
that red so you can't even see it
because the country is so small but
Israel is actually dark blue which means
that it is completely legal and
tolerated there and then interestingly
Lebanon which is right above Israel also
tiny right in the middle of that Red Sea
right there it is not illegal in Lebanon
but you know you I think you still can
be arrested or like this just it's not
quite protected but not totally illegal
sixty five countries not only allow gay
people I suppose but protect gay people
with laws so looking at that map is
there anything about that that surprises
you I mean the Middle East basically
that sort of Africa Middle East thing is
just seriously backwards yeah right so
ok so that's a good point I wanted to
bring that up so you can see if you look
at if you look at North America so the
United States Canada Mexico so illegal
so we're dark blue it's completely legal
you know we still don't have necessarily
gay marriage but you're not going to be
thrown in jail right
there's actually three towns right so
going to Russia though because that is a
good point so obviously Russia is up
there to the right so it is legal you it
is legal to be gay in Russia but but
these look but you can't promote it so
that's why Russia is not in the red so
don't show tunes yeah in Russia no show
Jews although they're apparently there
was a gay bar in Sochi that journalists
are going to so it's a little unclear
what's going on really lame gay bar I'm
sure that gay bar was a lot more fun
before the journalists came to be like
so what's the like big day here that's
what people were saying there that we
hadn't used to have fun here and now you
guys have all come here and ruined it
yeah but yeah this does anything on that
map surprised you know I mean
unfortunately it doesn't and it's it's
crazy that we still live in a time where
I mean I guess I guess maybe it's not
crazy maybe it's amazing how far the
other way look guys it's amazing how far
we've come in in sort of understanding
and basic human decency yeah but it is
shocking that so much of the world is
still is still backwards in that way and
it's also shocking that how the fact
that we give Russia the categorization
of legal when that lot we know that at
the same time they're roving bands of
people who are you know humiliating and
right and is there anything else that
you would have these different levels of
Okemos you put to death some countries
jail
some countries tolerated some countries
even here we do not as 2014 unite it is
not legal in every state to get married
yeah for gay people yeah I mean I can't
think I'm trying to think of anything
any other Liberty that's that has those
kind of hierarchies yeah I mean I can't
think of anything try it
come on Russia parts of Africa like give
it a shot like it'll be fun look cool
calm down it was interesting that was
that there was a slight oasis in the
middle of Africa right so a couple of
those countries with with the light-blue
in Africa that includes Mali nice years
a year so it's not all terrible there
but but it is pretty terrible
as a continent right it's I I mean I was
I was kind of kidding when I said they
should just try it but I do think that
one of the things that we have found is
that the the best antidote for
homophobia is knowing gay people yeah
and I think the more gay people there
are in the world and the more open
people are I mean you know Dan Savage
always gets kind of blasted for his sort
of like militant like everybody must be
completely out of the closet at all
times but like I do think there is
something to like the more openly gay
people there are worldwide the more
openly you know a lot of these places
became Christian because of missionaries
like missionaries are gay the homosexual
agenda just needs to be codified and
like it's like anything I mean the more
that you're exposed to something the
more you learn to tolerate it I mean I
mean my husband grew up in without any
Jews around and they used to express
same country's interesting and they used
to use this expression to juice somebody
down and never knew that it was you know
an unkind and bigoted thing to say
because they didn't know because they
didn't have anybody there is there a
connection between all this upheaval and
the in that part of the world and gay
rights like are like basic human rights
because they also if we were to look at
a map of women's rights it would be
pretty close to that map it's I think
it's a matter of the progressive world
meeting the unprogressive world the you
know the the West I mean I hate to say
the Western world has a lot Alonzo's in
those colors there yeah yeah yeah it's
it's you know I guess one of the great
things is despite all of our
frustrations about the really you know
the religious right sometimes and how
religion affects our country and policy
in our country it is still prove we
still have the the leeway to not let it
affect most things you know and I think
we take that for granted sometimes when
we you know these other places that they
don't even have the the pretend
separation of anything you know it's
very much theocracy and
last week was a Tom DeLay or somebody
was away is he back no I can't maybe I'm
not sure if it was he but somebody was
dancing with the Stars last night
somebody was saying that that the
problem is that that you know that
religion has gotten that gone out of
governments I mean somebody was saying
that oh yeah we need more Jesus in
government yeah for sure
wait so last thought on this and it sort
of goes back to the Ukraine thing how
much can the u.s. do about this how much
should we be leaning on all these
countries and saying you have you know
if I was living in Uganda and for
whatever reason I believed that stuff I
know it would piss me they're a
sovereign nation and kind of sovereign
nations just do what they want and what
right do we have do we have any right to
tell these countries what to do well
that's my old tired response again you
know education yeah you have to have
organizations that really can can help
and educate and and come into the
countries and instead of having
missionaries you know selling Jesus have
have organizations like nudists UNICEF
and and and you know organizations that
do that are they do well and don't have
an agenda yeah you know yeah i think i
think ngos and sort of funding for those
type of programs that you know promote a
more progressive tolerant world is is a
good thing it's it's always hard though
because they do think there's a we don't
know their world we don't know what life
is like there we you know and obviously
everybody should be able to live how
they you know live freely and live well
but it's also hard for you know us
sitting here in california to be able to
know exactly the the nitty gritty of on
the ground and how best to negotiate
those things but i don't know it's a
toto it's a tough question doing well
that's why i ask them
[Music]